détective, il y a une situation qui
exige le meilleur des meilleurs, nous allons où
les manoirs en briques et nous savons qui Tremaine
Alexander nous avons besoin de vous pour infiltrer
localiser l'appareil et le désarmer J'ai passé
toute ma carrière à essayer de faire tomber monsieur
je ne quitte jamais les manoirs en briques et
il y a  des points de contrôle partout s'il n'y a pas d'
informations à l'intérieur pas de glace nous avions vos yeux nous
connaissons l'expatrié français libre des Caraïbes
c'est s'il coopère il restera
sa petite amie parlons de cette
bombe que vous avez touchée il doit vous rendre un
peu anxieux en prenant mon aleksander
don  Je ne fais pas d'heure anxieuse parce que trois anxieux
Je pense que tout ce saut sur les
toits perd ses billes